(action music)
- [Narrator] By day, Guy Davis
is a normal college student,
but by night he's Action Guy.
(explosions)
Where's your costume?
- It doesn't say anything
about a costume party on here.
- [Narrator] Nevermind.
He keeps his fellow students
safe from harm at parties.
- Stop, I told you to stop.
- [Tall Man] Come on baby.
- [Blonde Woman]
No, I don't want to.
- Hey, man cut it out.
- [Narrator] Using
his superhuman
abilities of detection.
- What? I just heard
her, with my ears.
(action music)
- [Male In Brown Shirt]
You wanna go upstairs?
- I don't wanna go upstairs.
- Come on, are you sure?
- Stop touching me.
- Dude, she said no.
- [Narrator] Watch as
Action Guy faces down,
his arch nemesis, the
nefarious Jock Man.
- He's actually my
teammate and my friend.
- [Narrator] Nemesis.
- I'm getting weird vibes from
this dude in the other room.
- No way?
- Will you walk me home?
- [Narrator] For the
good of all the students,
he is the shining
beacon of justice.
He is, Action-
- Don't.
(crickets chirping)
- [Narrator] Whatever.
Action Guy.
- [Male Student] Let's go.
- [Female Student]
Get off of me!
Let me go!
- You don't even know me.
- [Female Student]
Let me go, let me go!
- Hey! Hey!
Get out of here!
- [Narrator] And
introducing Action Gal.
- You too, get out of here.
- [Narrator] I was just leaving.
(action music)